hey folks it's the [ __ ] roller it's
Friday yeah Rowland and his Friday what
did you just like want me to sit here
and not Star Trek all this man I can't
know everything he's sitting here front
of the microphone he's just like
surprised that I turned yeah tell you
what man is not enough people dying this
[ __ ] apocalypse man is getting too
boring
what if he battery people yeah I'm
looking at the dam looking at the
numbers in like what was projected which
really happened it's a lot less it's a
lot less that they know some people
might be dying without going to the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know
no they it's like one I think it was
like one third or what they project well
you want to asteroid to hit or something
no I'm just saying that I'm just saying
that I think would that make you know I
think the precautions that they took
we're more effective than they expected
well yeah that's well it's good that
actually people are now taking it
seriously and like actually doing what
they're supposed to be doing instead of
going around getting their grubby mitts
all over everything is bred in their
germs you know that [ __ ] wasn't deadly
wasn't maybe wasn't that deadly I don't
know but they they they knew what they
were dealing with it's just that they
had a projected a certain curve you know
they're trying to flatten it out spike
out that initial and it's much less well
me better to like they hope for that's a
way to tell people that it's gonna be
like worse than it is like to get people
to [ __ ] I thought what they're
supposed to be and I looked at the
numbers here at Seminole County where we
live and still just that one death from
like two weeks ago no no more
and it was it's up to like 50 people in
the hospital right now but it's been
like 40 something for two years
so and it's still like only 200
something people got it or tested
positive it's just not hitting us real
it's not hit well yeah like Seminole
County this county is kind of a lot of
its Earl yeah so people are kind of
farther apart the only one it's guy hit
hard was Miami dad Dade Dade yeah they'd
uh they'd learn to learn how to spell
that [ __ ] if it felt exactly the A's
da dee da de that stayed tomatoes just
odd
no dad would be DoD okay fight over this
is English I'm not talking about an e at
the end that usually makes it la dia
what I got a deal with [ __ ] Spock all
time Spock trying to she's a grammar not
sorry I'm smart
Graham and I got to find anything any
way I can describe anything in any way I
want to but yeah so we were actually
watching we came across this book and
movie on Netflix last night at random
yeah cuz we're reviewing and actually it
probably it's not gonna go up till
Sunday like the matinee show but we've
been talking about that
that's Korean series Kingdom it's on
Netflix it's like a zombie you know
thing but it's set like in the late
1500s the weird thing is we just kind of
randomly came across this movie on
Netflix let's say that came out in 2018
was just like it and it was almost
exactly the same premise and I thought
that was very odd it was called rampant
yeah as a Korean Korean historical movie
kinda like a samurai movie like I said
before with the zombie outbreak it's a
little bit different the way the zombies
are it wasn't as good as a series no
it's it was it was decent um it was
well-made I mean it was you could tell
it had a pretty big budget yeah but it's
just too many damn characters well I
think the the reason that Kingdom was so
good and like I said it was really weird
that it was like the same almost exactly
the same premise it was like a prince
that didn't really want to deal with the
[ __ ] like early on it was yeah the King
got infected there was a thing with the
zombies only being able to come out at
night like a vampire that was also in
Kingdom and [ __ ] like that so I was like
wow that's really interesting that that
that this came out I guess maybe a year
earlier although there probably like
working on him around the same time but
then I was remembering that Kingdom was
actually based on like a webcomic and I
can't find it anymore like I don't know
if it's been taken down just because
they thought oh well we'll republish it
like if the series is successful or
whatever but from what I could determine
the webseries started I guess before
2012 so
maybe they both got the idea from the
same thing and maybe cuz I didn't notice
like in the credits of rampant that they
had got the idea from that particular
webseries and I can't even figure out
what it's called like on Wikipedia said
it was called kingdom of the gods but
I've also seen it called by other names
you know what I mean so I'm not really
sure and I can't find it anywhere and
apparently like a lot of people are
looking for it now because Kingdom was
you know it was kind of popular it just
seemed kind of weird it was it's a good
movie but it didn't have I mean it had
like all the complicated like palace
intrigue and all this other kind of
stuff but because the movies only two
hours long they didn't have you didn't
get as invested in the characters
because they didn't have it had a big
cast and like they didn't have like
enough time for you to get into
everybody you know what I mean it like
you know care about their journey and
care about what was happening them
whereas in Kingdom you know they had
like 12 hours to play with roughly it's
worth seeing it is yeah it's just I just
thought it was funny that it was like
almost exactly the same that premise
that premise makes more sense in a
series they try to do palace intrigue
which I guess is a feature of Locke
Korean movies are talking about their
you know their their their their Middle
Ages you know or they're you know what
do you call it not Middle Ages but
they're [ __ ]
you know their version of the damn
samurai days is in the 1500s the stories
about Chosun yeah and those stories
usually have a bunch of powell century
again it yeah so when they're mixing
genres they're gonna have that pow
century with that but for a movie and
they shouldn't have had any of that well
it's it's a little complex to get into
in a two hour movie should have been a
fun romp with like three characters that
were different or two characters are
different and they had to do some [ __ ]
in ancient shows on yeah show South
Korea and a zombie outbreak that way
like like a like a two-part episode of
The Walking Dead that's what it should
have been like yeah just survival not so
much the palace intrigue and pretty
costumes and stuff you know cuz like you
said it's really hard too hard to pack
it into something that complicated like
in one move
like you as opposed to like this big
long series I just thought it was so
weird though guess what else even more
important than Korean zombies what could
possibly be more important only one
thing that'd be more important than
Korea zombies what's that the tiger king
yeah yeah that [ __ ] is still number one
they're gonna have a bonus episode of
the tiger cave I heard that yeah I heard
that yeah I didn't know if it was
actually I didn't know if that was just
like a rumor of this but I read
something about it a couple days ago
evidently they just got put some more
out there they're gonna just do some
updates cuz I don't think it's [ __ ]
hilarious I don't think they really
understood like how it would just take
the nation by storm a lot of that had to
do with well it wasn't just the
characters involved it was the Edit to
man the [ __ ] the Edit of that [ __ ]
series is the [ __ ] it's just hilarious
well the order in which they told you
things you know yeah because like I said
you it you just thought I couldn't
possibly get any crazier and they kept
topping itself and topping itself on top
we got to watch that [ __ ] again yeah we
probably show you like in preparation
for the new one coming out also tonight
I mean it's Friday we'll probably record
the next show tonight but I'm not going
to tell you what it's about it's it's
back to - it's back to true crime though
and I've been like study in the person
all day but um also I think because
remember I mentioned that new shutter
series cursed films or cursed movies or
cursed cinema or whatever the [ __ ] it's
called what it's like a documentary
series and I think they're putting up
the new episodes every Friday so I
watched The Exorcist one last Friday so
I don't know what the one I know like I
said I know they're gonna do one on
poltergeist I don't remember what the
other series is gonna be talking about
but I guess that'll be on tonight too so
maybe a lot of time to watch that like
after we finish recording the show if
I'm not too inebriated
so maybe movie theaters are still
suffering in the apocalypse comic book
industry it's [ __ ] Safran theaters
what else do you think is gonna be next
can you do you have any ideas what would
affect what something might affect
something else I think I have I think I
know what's gonna happen next
what's that University's
yeah maybe cuz well because like I said
so many people do [ __ ] online now anyway
well think about this right yeah think
about this you got universities and
really you can only really only can
reliably make money with the hard
sciences out of them right now they
don't the social science is their work
at Starbucks so why the hell would you
want to spend that amount of money I
remember when that scam happened I was
in high school and they told us about
that scam that was common that everyone
was gonna have to go to a college to get
a job that that would be the new high
school diploma and that all the
manufacturing stuff would disappear
because you know we're too good for that
and we're gonna have you know social
studies degrees that [ __ ] didn't work
out they can't feel an economy on it but
really what it was about it was about it
was about banks yeah I mean banks making
loans to these colleges and then somehow
getting the tax payer to cover those
bank loans and bank bailouts like we saw
happen in that last out crash so I think
the next one to be hit our universities
I bet you a lot of universities will
close because during the recovery
process why would the hell would you go
back to finish your social studies
degree which is most of that [ __ ] that
they're teaching them is if you add it
all up when you're not able to make
money with that in the in the upcoming
economy they can't make money with it
now well like I said I think it'll just
be kind of like [ __ ] yeah it'll just go
online which a lot of the [ __ ] is done
anyway yeah and there's like tons of
services out there that you can just pay
there's even stuff like Skillshare and
[ __ ] like that we just pay like 10 bucks
a month or however much it is and you
can take classes and pretty much
whatever you want and it'll like teach
you how to do stuff if you trace it back
to the University where all the
university was is a damn religious
institution back in the 1600s where you
sent your boys and they got just a
general education it was you know and
the new look they learned a little bit
of science a little bit of history a
little bit of literature was like a
general education and then they got a
kind of like stamp of social approval it
was kind of like passing [ __ ]
something from the Catholic Church it
was that's kind of how it started some
of the some of the
well that live there the professor's you
know they were geniuses but the people
coming in and out were just getting the
damn piece of paper like a golden
parachute and that went on for a long
time and then it became more and more
important I guess in the 1800s and then
early 1900s but a lot of that was
centered around the fact that you needed
libraries you know yeah you don't need
libraries anymore or less its online you
don't really need a centralized place to
go you could do like yeah like I said
you can do pretty much everything
everything online nowadays which means
every day is gonna be kind of like right
and you might go do online testing to
live and yeah you can and you know
people would cheat but they've been
cheatin yeah the benching and then they
go to those days and cheating yourself
yeah go to those damn lectures and you
know a lot of times it's not the
professor giving the lecture it's a damn
student another student teacher or
something somebody works for a professor
you never see the professors you give
you a stack of books tell you to write
it write a report on it
it's kind of lame you know I did some
like um I did some classes and if you
look around I can't remember the name of
this service but I did like a whole [ __ ]
ton for free like it it but you could do
I did like an astronomy one I did like a
[ __ ] like a history one like a
European history from whatever year to
whatever year it was just like somebody
and it was like real teachers it was
like real they gave you reading material
why would you pay for an astronomy why
would you pay for an astronomy degree
you not make money with that anyway well
some people probably do for an
observatory
yeah but I don't think they make that
much money I heard that I heard most of
the hard sciences you don't really make
any money especially the mathematics
stuff yeah the ones where you really
make money from what my understanding is
stuff like Chemical Engineering
yeah and it's because they go work for
the damn oil industry well I mean you
you see stuff like you know somebody
like Neil deGrasse Tyson or something
like that it's like yes you can make
money getting it if you're like kind of
a popular educator if you can write
books you know popular science books and
[ __ ] like that you know you can make a
lot of money on this a lot of that [ __ ]
when I was a kid going to college was
about getting a degree so you can get a
white-collar job and work in a [ __ ]
office it didn't have anything yeah
that's all it was
because I think that those offices are
all gone I think that at the time what
they were doing like you know like a
long time ago it was like the high
school diploma but they wanted to see if
you had the discipline to like study
something and pass like for 4 more years
you know so then they'd know that you
were gonna be a good employee yeah
because you could handle like 4 years of
study and just saying and just like
getting back to what we're talking about
yes sir yesterday eventually the age of
the white collar employee will advantage
there won't you won't if you're a white
collar worker if that's what we want to
call it you won't be working for other
people you'll be online if I can work it
for yourself and you know I mean if you
don't have the discipline work for
yourself and you gonna [ __ ] go out of
business get out of it yeah all the
offices that [ __ ] I wanted to work in
what first of all you didn't want to
work in I mean you just thought you
wanted to work on him when you were a
kid well you didn't really want to work
in him you just wanted make the money
yeah you know like have a sociable life
right but you know but that should that
was as much as you were thinking about
yeah that [ __ ] fell apart quit that [ __ ]
fell apart soon though because even like
even jobs that I thought would be cool
when I was a kid when you actually have
it very few of them are cool right you
know what I mean sorry kids yeah that's
funny the dudes making all the money or
the damn plumbers plumbers and the
electricians I don't know my brother's
an electrician and he's not me he's not
making any money and some states have to
heard of plumber can make over $100,000
a year depends where you are yeah that's
my I understand okay you will pay a man
anything to get [ __ ] out of your house
yeah ii and my dad's best friend [ __ ]
he installs those damn carrier air
conditioning central air conditioning
systems and everything you know does
makes the duct work and everything that
do makes money hand-over-fist cuz in
Mississippi you will pay anything to get
that AC I feel like well I've always
thought that that was a good thing to go
into in Florida too because there were a
lot of people like even the college I
went to there was a lot of people in the
AC and refrigeration yeah program which
was all it sounds like a two-year
program they teach you all the [ __ ] you
know what I mean I was working for them
in the summer of nose addicts [ __ ]
working on duck
just sweating my ass off or crawling
underneath the damn floor doing floor
units and trailers that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
but it's like a sit down makes seven
hundred dollars that day I didn't make
seven huh but he would make seven
hundred well yeah my throw me a hundred
I mean they judge a lot like for the
liver and stuff but it's not I mean I
don't know like maybe you could probably
make money doing that in Florida too
like you said because everybody needs
air-conditioning like you don't have
air-conditioning your house will fall
apart in weeks yeah it's just it'll be
like mold everywhere yeah well like in a
few in the matter of days you're living
in Dagobah yeah I just feel like to that
there's a lot of competition because a
lot there's a lot of a/c companies
yeah probably around here and yeah and a
lot of them are like small businesses
it's just like one or two guys with a
van yeah I mean that's what it was in
Mississippi just there weren't very many
of them I mean people were offering you
hundreds of dollars on top of the job
the bonus to move move them to the front
of the line please I'll give you an
extra 300 bucks if you can get me
tomorrow yeah you know which reminds me
you remember a while back when we said
yeah during the whole epochal just seems
like a minor thing to complain about but
our [ __ ] dryer broke yeah yeah so we
heard the part and we got it and we put
it in there and that and it wasn't that
it fixed the door problem but that's
what it didn't fix so then I've got all
these different sensors I took the back
off and I got all these little different
sensors and you can check them for
continuity and [ __ ] but the man I'd have
to dig in there and find out what
sensors what and [ __ ] what what
[ __ ] what's what each one is supposed
to read and then open I don't really
want to do it and the thing is it's like
it's a lot of if an appliance is gonna
break I mean the dryer seems to be the
best one to break I would rather that
break than the washing machine okay
great I check the thermal shutoff it's
not that yeah so it hasn't really I mean
it's kind of a pain but it's not really
that much of pain cuz the washing
machines still work and so you just wash
it and then we just like kind of hang it
yeah just hang it up that's a little
little [ __ ] yeah we just have to do like
a little bitty load every day and then
just like put it like it like do the
sheet see the sheets today the sheets
room was Ryan I said [ __ ] it I put him
in a car but a minute
it's hot as [ __ ] their prime a prime
been dry for an hour [ __ ] out that car
yeah my solar heater yeah dryer it's
silver
yeah my car is silver and it's like
black it even better be better for it
but it's not it's silver yeah but yeah
so it's a it gets warm out there so it's
not really that big a deal like I said I
probably I didn't I hope I didn't like
jinx it now the [ __ ] washing
machine's gonna break and that would
really suck everything couldn't give you
a guy out here
well yeah nobody's working yeah you know
what I mean cuz that's not essential and
it ordered that switch it took like an
extra six days yeah well like I said I
ordered memory for my computer but they
said that's not even come until the end
of this month which I don't care I don't
need it like immediately or anything and
I would rather like people that had you
know that needed [ __ ] would get it but
um you know what I mean so you know same
kind of [ __ ] going on
same same nothing really we're just kind
of sit around drink and watch the movies
and it's gonna be alright recording this
[ __ ] and like getting ready for the next
show I was wait yeah I got that [ __ ]
oven preheating I got a pizza stone on
there I let me eat pizza while trying to
lose weight well yeah but if that's all
you eat if that's all you had made the
dough yesterday see it rising cuz he
wanted to make you wanted to make the
pizza last night that's be honest yeah
and I'm like dude I already ate to make
dough I made sauce yeah and then he was
like hey I got some Calabrese and I'm
like dude o'clock p.m. it's like I can't
eat pizza I already ate like a pork chop
them race I wish I had yesterday you had
some mushrooms I wish we had mushrooms
too but I don't want to go to the store
and get cooties like to get just to get
mushrooms I can I can eat it with all
eat pizza with pretty much anything on
it to be honest with you there's a good
there's stuff that I like more than
other things but I'm not super picky
yeah pizzas good no matter what's on
there pretty much I think I even like
pineapple fight me yeah yeah I don't
want I know a lot of people don't like
pineapple and ham oh they don't have any
they don't have any class any class man
I'm right now not all the time but it's
like equation these people
time talking about pizza they don't want
to hear this [ __ ]
they wouldn't be listening if you guys
like this please like share subscribe
everybody seems to like the new side
tracks they do get likes but you know
they only get like 200 views but if we
had 200 likes
we might get some new people to come in
people might watch a bore I don't know
yeah but I mean we still hit the st.
they hit they hit many shows I mean we
just started doing these mostly just for
family keep everybody like there's not
as much YouTube material going online
there's a shortage of material going up
because a lot of people might not be
able to do it and like even some of the
shows that I like like beer and board
games they're still doing it but now
they have to do it like remotely so like
each of the four guys is like in a
different location and they're doing it
over Skype or FaceTime or whatever it's
still funny and like it still works but
you can see it started to dry up I had
to follow [ __ ] other idiots muscle
hands you idiots yeah muscle although
some people are still putting like
Oliver Harper just put up a new one
Brandon tunnel you just put up a new one
so they're still doing cuz they're
mostly just like one guy you know in a
room anyway so it wasn't like a big deal
but a show night though - yeah we got a
record a show tonight yeah
so that's probably what we'll do have a
drink in but yeah we're gonna go have
some pizza and you know we'll make the
pizza yeah we're gonna eat it but yeah
you guys have the rest of the day have a
good rest of the day and we will talk to
you again tomorrow